hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to anxiety attacks now this
is actually a very different game from
many games that I've played in the past
because I don't even know what that said
because it's supposed to simulate the
idea of having an anxiety attack and the
whole game is based around that because
I've turned on the ability for these
subliminal messages to be bombed at you
at random so as with many of the games
that cover a very serious subject matter
this is going to be very serious so
watch with an open mind and remember oh
what was that what is it telling me see
I personally don't have anxiety but I
know that a lot of you guys out there
actually do so watch with caution as
with most things in this game that is
actually really jarring and it's it's
supposed to not be quite a game and more
of an experience because it's like a
simulation but not a simulation some
where's I don't know what that's said
but not a simulation in the way that
typical simulation games not like goat
simulator or anything like that cuz God
that is so jarring it's literally like
jolting me in place oh man that's not
okay I don't even know what that says
hi
help ya it said at the beginning that it
wasn't quite a horror experience but
there's a little bit of horror aspect to
it because I'm like going what are you
saying
stop doing that to me I'm kind of going
out of my skin trying just to get the
place where I need to go so Y is so what
I'm trying to do is I'm trying
goddamn I'm trying to breathe properly
with the inhalation and exhalation of
the bars down at the bottom I'm supposed
to press a button at the right time it's
supposed to go in and out please help me
Tim what is what is that
is that a plane going overhead or
something else entirely
man I'm not my anxiety levels price
flaring up like I can't see something I
can't see what that said and I gotta
find ten of these spots holy crap
now help now I know that a lot of people
out there have anxiety and I know that a
lot of people get a lot of relaxation
out of my videos I don't know so much
about the horror videos but whoa whoa
what is that
Oh get out God what is that oh my god
that's not okay Oh No Oh God is this
what it's like Oh God I don't want to do
this I'm trying to breathe it's not
working very well okay just calm down
calm down okay there we go now we're
breathing breathing breathing breathing
breathing and we're okay it's getting
okay it's getting better
oh damn that was terrifying see this is
weird because Oh God not another one I'm
trying to be calm here I'm okay I'm okay
got to find the peaceful zones got to
find my Center got to breathe easy it
took away like the key prompts for
breathing in and out so now I'm just on
my own completely
this stressful I wish I was wearing like
a heart monitor this so I could see
exactly how high my anxiety actually is
right now goddamn this is an experience
and it's just the first part of the game
trying to find the peaceful zones oh my
god this is like jarring I got my skin
crawling while I'm going through this is
not okay oh man for some reason the
exhalation isn't working as well as the
inhalation is I'm gonna make it cuz I'm
a peaceful butterfly floating through
the woods nothing's gonna stop me I'm
having a relaxed full peaceful day I
don't even think relaxed full is a word
but that doesn't matter because I'm
a-okay here in the woods markiplier is
enjoying life in the peaceful serenity
that follows this is gorgeous I'm having
a great day I hope I don't have another
anxiety attack I mean man like seriously
from someone that's never had anxiety or
another one oh god not another one oh no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no I'm okay I'm
breathing I'm doing uh breathing uh I
don't know where the other peaceful
spots is I don't know where to find them
they don't seem to be incredibly obvious
man all right I'll be right back once I
find more of them so I'll be right back
with you guys okay I was going the
complete wrong direction I think I think
I like started in the middle and then
went one direction and thought that was
the only way around no no no no I'm okay
I'm okay
I don't need it thank you I'm fine I got
plenty of Girl Scout cookies I'm okay
back off please
come okay
okay so yeah I think I went the wrong
way but but I think I got him now how
I'm getting this breathing down pretty
good
it's weird because the more I play it
the more I'm kind of just tuning out ah
not that but I'm tuning out the random
in truth of and intrusive thoughts that
pop up in front of it oh god not again
oh wow okay we're fine we're fine fine
fine we're fine everyone just relax
we're fine - deep breaths deep breaths
in and out everything's fine
don't listen to the random intrusive
thoughts everything's fine everything's
okay everything's peaceful gonna come
out of it just okay I'm more talking to
myself than you guys at the moment here
it's man I mean I I can't fathom this if
like this like this is obviously a
simulation but if it's even a fraction
of what this is in real life and man I
don't know how to deal with that
something I've never experienced I've
had maybe a panic attack once in my life
oh come on I'm not even out of this one
it's fine
everything's fun
gotta keep moving forward gotta keep
breathing and moving forward there's the
next peaceful zone two more and I'm good
oh nana i keep missing up on the
breathing
ha the last zone is often the hardest to
find is that a haiku is that some life
lessons there I can't exactly move Oh No
have faith it's there somewhere focus
well I don't know maybe a little hint
would be a little bit helpful while the
forest is full of dark demons that are
trying to claim my soul be patient and
keep breathing well that doesn't sound
good at all been patiently breathing the
whole time you need to tell me where it
is because I don't want to be in this
woods anymore I want to be back in my
home gonna take a nap hold a seat chika
hold a pen my doggy no gosh no oh gosh
oh golly gosh oh gosh and that anxiety
is creeping in on me I'm a peaceful
butterfly floating through the woods I
wonder if I just wandered off into the
distance over there that it would do
anything for me
oh man stop that no I'm okay I'm a
breather oh I'm a breather I'm a
breathing breathe er I'm a breathing
breathing breathing through the woods
everything's gonna be a-okay I'm
impotence I'm not impotent you're
impotent oh man
whoa whoa whoa gosh
hot damn he breathing
Oh keep breathing keep breathing breathe
breathe breathe breathe breathe breathe
just breathe focus on your happy place
focus on everything being okay
everything is okay and everything is
gonna be okay
everything's fine everything is
absolutely fine
I know everything's fine
everything's fine his little attacks
will pass we're gonna find the last
peaceful zone and everything will be
a-okay
trust me I believe in you everything is
gonna be just fine
just listen to the sound of my voice and
keep breathing in and out no matter what
you got to keep reason just in and out
now like I'm doing I'm doing this
stupidly
you guys can do way better than I can
you're like expert breathers have you
been breathing professionally for a long
time very good I have no idea what's
last peaceful zone this
yeah
everything's fine everything's a-okay Oh
you can't get me you can't beat me I'm
the best breather this side of the
Mississippi
I hope we're nowhere near Mississippi oh
I see it oh I see it
I see it in the distance it's gonna be
ok ha ha everything's gonna be ok so
just listen to the soft sounds in my
voice and just remember to keep
breathing in and out we're gonna get
through this one we're gonna hit this
one head-on cuz it can beat us
it can't beat me it can't beat you
it can't be me and it ain't gonna beat
you
we're tougher than this we're better
than this we're better than everything
this can throw at us cuz we're great
yep that's it easy we got this no
problem no problem don't even knowledge
anything it's cool it's fine well is
that cool obviously but it's fine yeah I
got it
EPIK combos
almost there
oh we're gonna get through this one too
BAM you can't be me huh you think you're
better than me you think you're better
the answer is no you're not
hey God never know me I'm the greatest
I'm the greatest it was
you're the greatest that ever was we're
all great that's something I'm great at
breathing I'm the number one breathing
nationally I won state Bravin Owen
County breathing how's high school
varsity breathing champion you ain't
gonna be this breather
nobody will ya I'm coming for you in the
breathing championship okay we're almost
there
whoo and
you ain't got me yeah we did it yeah I
don't know what that accomplished but I
feel good
lots of breathing it's good breathing
now you're out of safe places an easy
solution anxiety is still here though oh
okay then well we already learned how to
beat it so I guess we're fine you have
to beat anxiety at the roots okay who do
I punch where are the gonads of the
anxiety I'm gonna punch him so hard
escape this cage follow the Sun there's
a thin flowery path there for you to
find okay yeah that sounds more
metaphysical than an actual solution but
so long as there are some gonads that it
can be punched I'm ready to punch him so
where's the sin seems to be a lot of
bloom going on I don't exactly know
which one's a Sun I'm just gonna go away
from the sounds of death and hopefully
everything will be okay
yeah pink oh come on that was good combo
hmm that's good breathing it's so
peaceful
I gotta admit the map them the music is
good and the environment is pretty
typical but it still looks pretty pretty
pretty pretty pretty this pretty pretty
forest is very pretty on my pretty face
pretty for my eyeballs pretty everything
around me pretty flowers I'm a pretty
butterfly floating through the forest is
this the flowery path that I need to
follow probably I see I got it I got it
I got the flowery path so long flower
doesn't say something to me yeah I made
an undertale reference what of it okay
we're reaching the end of the path is
there something here for me to see oh
well that doesn't sound good I did it I
did it I want an award maybe a medal you
know just a simple gold slash platinum
diamond medallion will be do something
humble for me you're trying to beat
anxiety but anxiety is useful to you is
it I've just been punching it in the
gonads
how is it useful listen to your body and
mind embrace anxiety let it flow okay
that seems a little counterintuitive but
you're the expert you need anxiety to
change start making a change to improve
your life now okay how I go to the gym
every morning I can crush a baby's skull
do do it okay wait all right Wow
concept isn't oh okay I guess that's the
end of it that was actually really cool
because in the beginning like obviously
this game this isn't exactly what
anxiety is this isn't an accurate
representation to the tee I'll leave
that to you guys to the side I know
there's some of my viewers out there
that do have anxiety in him I'm sorry
that you have to go through that because
that was not terribly fun during the
anxiety attacks I mean it was a game
obviously it was kind of fun but like I
I hope I hope that you guys who have
anxiety out there have different ways to
cope about it oh one last thing it may
sound cheap to say but listen and follow
your dreams yeah that's good enough
advice that's never cheap to say I mean
it's good because I I don't know how
much you can channel anxiety but I've
often talked about or else sooner or
later your body will force you to
well that sounds weird so that was
anxiety attacks and I don't know how
accurate that representation of what
anxiety is portrays but just so you guys
out there that do have anxiety and watch
my videos I want to say thank you guys
so much for watching and also I'm sorry
you have to put up with that in your
daily life I hope you have ways to cope
about it and it was really interesting
the way it said use your anxiety to
change yourself or else he'll change no
matter what and I don't know how
accurate that is and I can't speak for
the truth of the matter because I'm not
a psychologist I'm not trained in the
field but I can speak to my own
experiences because there's a lot of
things that I am afraid of and fear and
anxiety kind of play together but
there's a lot of things that I'm afraid
of and I've talked about this before in
the past and on once again I can only
use my personal experiences for this but
I'm afraid of a lot of things you know
I'm afraid of failure I'm afraid of
disappointing people I'm afraid of you
know not being as good as I think I am
and you know I'm afraid of not living up
to my full potential and things like
that and that's a very minut quality of
what anxiety is and I know for a fact
and I know people that have anxiety and
it's just very detrimental and the
intrusive thought thing is there so like
I hope this like brought about the
experience of anxiety so that other
people can understand it better
especially because empathy is important
but when it comes to me and the message
then it'd have had I kind of understand
because you want to use those fears and
the things that make you afraid of
moving forward to push you even farther
because I use my fear of failure to try
to motivate myself to be better you know
I'm afraid of not being good enough so I
try very hard you know almost to the
point of overcompensating but I try very
hard to be as good as I can be and I may
never live up to my expectations because
I am afraid and I set the bar very high
for myself but I use that to channel
change in myself and that's not a
perfect scenario for everyone out there
that's not going to be a fix-all for all
you guys out there but I just want to
say that for those of you who do have
anxiety and other you know disorders and
other things like depressions things
like that there is hope you know at the
end of the dark tunnel there is hope out
there and there are people that are
willing to help and and there's people
that you could reach out to and that's
one of the great things about this
community here that we have you know
there's other people you know there's
bad eggs in the comments section but for
the most part there's a lot of people
though out there that are willing to do
good and reach out and help people so
just know that there are people that are
going through the exact same things some
people have it worse
some people have it better you know but
there are people out there that are
willing to help so if you need help
reach out for it there's things that you
can do for yourself and at the end of
day it's going to be a battle with
yourself but you don't have to face that
battle alone you will have to jump over
hurdles yourself and only you can push
yourself to do that but once you get out
there there's other people that are
willing to help so please if you are
experiencing anxiety depression any sort
of mental illness please reach out for
help it will mean the world of
difference to your friends and family
and most of all yourself so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for experiencing this with me I hope you
enjoyed it no matter what it was a fun
interesting experience and it actually
opened my eyes to a different way of
thinking that I've never thought before
so thanks again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
by anything